okay so the big story in Sports this
week University of Missouri Michael Sam
came out of the closet and now it
appears that he is going to be the first
openly gay football player in the NFL is
this going to destroy professional
football as we know it the straw you're
the pro is this is this going to be okay
is everyone gonna be okay we gotta get a
couple these out the pro by the way
you're the pro sports guy no I mean it's
not gonna destroy professional football
why why would it I mean here's a thing
ESPN put out this piece and they
interviewed you know Copeland who he is
great friends with and they also
interviewed a few other players and they
showed the positive sides there are many
negative sides that we're not seeing to
this jason whitlock even tweeted that
look locker rooms are tough there's a
lot of homophobia involved they show the
positive side there is a negative side
but it doesn't mean it doesn't mean that
it's going to destroy professional
football just because of one man's
choices that's the most ridiculous thing
and I know and I'm not going to ask a
guy like me when it I know I know I know
but no it's not the store professional
been the locker room thing can they deal
with it will the players built it will
Michael Sam not be able to jump on every
player the way that they say he's going
through uh you know Rick's point is
valid the bring it up with Jason
Whitlock said of course there will be
some negativity in the locker room but
so what I mean here is when the Jackie
Robinson example applies directly there
was there we get a locker room was an
issue uh and they got beyond it because
we have to get beyond it that's what is
vitally necessary you know your opposite
kind of play you know that that's yeah
look at me help a little bit yeah it's
hard to tell because you know there's
clearly some general managers who don't
think this kid should have come out that
it hurt his potential or money-making
potential may have hurt his chances of
making it in the NFL we don't know
fingers crossed that there will at least
because it only takes one team to
recognize there's talent here so I hope
he makes it I don't believe ever I I
hope not everyone who's saying he might
not get drafted is right is part of the
draft thing though not that he's coming
out but that a team I sort of think
there's some validity to this that a
team might say we just don't want a
season's worth of crazy media
distraction that is a legitimate
argument i'm not defending it by any
stretch but i can understand an
organization saying it no matter what it
was gay whatever we don't want some sort
of distraction riding us along the
entire that's horseshit I think it's
wrong why Jason Collins been sign that
but what which is about was a
phrenologist 35 years old average the
point the rebound like like it's
entirely possible that is totally
valuable too many NBA team i tried i
truly think they did on the baggage that
came with it if you want to compete in
the playoffs and have that one guy go in
and grab a few rebounds again why not
updation collins we ended last year with
the Wizards imagine if you were still
with the Wizards you think it'd be a
circus the wizard locker room I don't
think so so I mean it can't get worse
than to parse crittenton so so I just
think that that argument there always
distractions and those distractions
eventually go away that when he arrives
in camp if he makes that and Willie make
the team will that be a big deal yeah it
will be so you know what teams can do
instead of having reporters able to walk
around the locker room as they usually
do they'll stop that and they'll bring
guys out and they'll have a press
conference and it'll be a little more
difficult you might have to hire
somebody else but the world is changing
and the sports world can lead the way
and the fact and it has it has in the
past and the fact that it that some in
the sports world now are talking about
doing the exact opposite and retarding
growth in an area like this is shameful
for sport yeah just solve it you can
solve it's not that big a description
distraction and guaranteed after two or
three weeks it does so final thought on
this so isn't that the cool part of this
that we got already the president is
tweeting the guy congratulations ESPN
has been absurdly behind this i mean the
coverage is is non-stop so as a sports
talk guy we're where does this sort of
fit into how much you have to pay
attention to it and because it is
important but then again it's not about
the sport specifically on okay so i know
we need a wrap-up and I here's basically
my last point uh those people who think
that Jason Collins or two DJ's accounts
that Michael Sam is you know wrong for
coming out and whatnot it's who he is
like again it's not gonna destroy NFL
locker rooms it's not gonna kill the
sport at all he's still a person he's
still a human being those same people
might make a better player actually to
actually be out oh sure double on the
field yet no I mean like those are the
same people that thought like women
should vote
note that slaves are three fifths of a
man like those are the same people that
literally do do not cope with what
people are and who exactly they are so I
think it'll be fine I think he will be
fine it'll be a bigger news story if he
makes the practice squad over making the
team in my opinion just because the
initial thing yes but then bring us on
so he texted his father he doesn't ever
good enough relationship with his father
that he just said of attacks that his
dad some people talked about this his
dad was at Denny's yeah when he got the
text and Michael Sam senior said I
couldn't eat no more he's at Denny's so
I went to applebees I thought you were
kidding burns later for a drink we had
one of those I know the lessons a guy
said I lost my appetite at Denny's so I
went to applebees I don't my grandkids
race in that kind of environment
indicating that baby didn't want his
grandkids raised at applebee see uh so
and then he said he supports his son but
not after you say that first that's not
support you said between I thought you
were kidding no that's real good and I
don't know if you're not happy about
this thing go get wasted at Applebee's
and these things will generally work
themselves out